hey on today's show we talk about a lot
of light and a lot of dark
we talk about fractured marriages and
parenting
we talk about healing from grief after a
loss of a child
and we talk about healing after sexual
abuse it's a heavy show
but a good one stay tuned
hey what's up i'm john this is the dr
john delony show thank you for hanging
out
thanks for showing up thanks for putting
your earbuds in while you're
mowing the lawn or vacuuming or driving
or painting the house i don't know
whatever it is you're doing
but i'm so glad you're here we're
talking about relationships mental
health
um dating marriage things falling apart
people passing away all of it whatever's
going on your heart mind
give us a shout nine 1-844-693
thirty two ninety one okay that's one yo
eight four four six nine three three two
nine one what's up
i have a uh an apology to ask of you and
apparently of our listeners
you have an apology to ask of me or to
tell me no okay let's walk it back i'm
not
i'm not asking for your forgiveness
when i made the comment you making horse
noises
um i jokingly was like oh people are
probably gonna say we love that well it
wasn't a joke kelly told me today that
we have gotten
loads of emails of people saying hey
leave him alone we like the horse noises
so of course
you're of course that would happen so
i'm not going to stop you anymore it's
equine therapy brother
it's awesome you nae as much as you want
to and i won't stop you anymore
and there's a strong eunay
is it the nae nae is that the dance that
just i just made that weird i'm sorry
thank you for the uh
yeah yeah um yeah watch me whip watch me
nae nae
see i will not do that i can assure
america
i'm pretty sure that was my mom sending
those uh this just flooded kelly's inbox
she'd open a new gmail account and then
a yahoo account
but james i won't accept your apology
because you didn't give one
i should have done a listener survey
before i i i'm not chomping at the bit
to get you to see what i did oh my gosh
what a dad that's the most
that's ah it's the worst hey
for those of you who are still with us
after that terrible terrible dad joke i
apologize
please write in to the show um you can
go to johnny.com
show and write in how offended you were
by that terrible dad joke
from james child so there we go good
folks
listen i'm not gonna bring the horse
noise back i don't mean it's like
if you don't know what i'm talking about
i when i get frustrated or i don't know
what to do
some radio folks are so good with coming
in and out of these breaks and they're
like
oh as we transition or let's take a turn
to i just go
and james said that sounded like i was a
horse and it hurt my feelings
and so to america thanks for reaching
out
and by america i mean all 18 of you and
my mom
and seriously mom you gotta just lay off
it's cool kelly's she's a good person
she's taking care of us it's good
all right let's go to the phones today
man let's go to um
i'm glad we got to see your heart james
he doesn't even have one it's so great
all right let's go to mike in
seattle uh let's see here what's up mike
how are we doing
hey doc john thanks for taking my call
you got it bro what can i do man
i've got a stepson that's 11. uh we have
a lot of problems with
respect in the home uh causes a lot of
a lot of issues between my wife and i
yeah and uh
his his dad and his biological father
died before he was born
hmm yikes man i'm sorry
so he never got to meet him huh no okay
so you're the only dad he's ever known
right yeah
how long did he live with um
how long was mom a single mom before you
came into the picture
uh till he was seven seven okay
so tell me about what you mean by
disrespect
uh you know
it's kind of broad um some days we'll
we'll be talking and interact with each
other he'll just turn around and walk
away
and uh most days he just he just will
not do what he's told
around the house okay um anything from
just not following our basic rules of
the house yeah
not even his chores and homework and
things like that
and to everyday stuff does he do that to
your
to your wife too or just to you no
mostly just me i mean some of it to my
wife but not
not as much as me
what uh man i hate that for you i can
hear it on you
so kids all this this is a
a different situation a little bit but
not totally
kids learn respect by watching respect
right and
kids lean up against boundaries to see
if they're real or not
so first question is how does he
see respect modeled in you
you're the first man that's ever um
had that presence in his life how do you
model what respect looks like
uh
i guess just just how he sees me
interact with the world i
i act the same around him that i do
anybody else
um that's what i'm getting at he didn't
i interact
um something about you something about
him just turning and walking away in the
middle of a conversation
is an 11 year old saying you're you're
you're not worth my time old man right
um right i've got or
the first guy didn't even never showed
up
and i want to see if you're going to
come get me there's another way to look
at that
and i want to see if i push and i push
and i push are you still going to be
there are you still going to be there
you're still going to be there
and what are some moments you guys
have together that
he is respectful we all can connect
um
when we go out and do things one-on-one
okay
i have a speed boat we take that boat
out and that's uh
that's generally a good time okay we
don't have we don't have any issues with
them
turning around and walking away or just
being blatantly disrespectful
there's you didn't see anything sideways
or do anything crazy
yeah does there other kids in the house
too
yeah my wife and i have a two-year-old
okay
so not only did he get a new dad but he
got new competition right
yeah yeah how did
mom process loss
as far as uh his father
all right let me ask you this let me ask
you this way was
her son y'all's son was he the solution
to
four or five years of grieving
no i don't know that there was much
grieving there i don't think that they
had much of a relationship
okay okay gotcha
um hmm okay
so there's a couple things you can do
here man one is
um let me back up before i start giving
you solutions here
um tell me about your marriage how does
it impact you guys
cool um there's a lot of second guessing
my wife is very uh
defensive okay and uh
so if i react a certain way and she
doesn't like it
it turns into uh
it turns it turns into an upset
household right i mean
i'll be dealing with my stepson and then
all of a sudden
i'll have to deal with my wife as well
ah that's that's it man that's why she
doesn't have that's why he doesn't
respect you or listen to you because it
doesn't sound like she does either
if y'all aren't on the same page with
how we're gonna all be unified as a
family who respects one another and
and has fun together and laughs together
et cetera
um he's not gonna do that either and so
i actually
screwed up here man i was looking to you
like how are you modeling respect
but the real challenge is man if she's
gonna disagree with the way you respond
to something
in in view of hi man he's got no use for
you because mom is the og
mom's the original right right and so
let's back out of this way back
what do the conversations look like with
you and your wife before this stuff gets
going
like do you all have a common sense of
purpose when it comes to raising kids or
is she going to protect this son with
all of her might and she's also married
to you
well we do i i should add one more layer
of complexity here i also have adhd
and we have a we have a dynamic going on
there that's
difficult to deal with as well
as far as us parenting i think we're in
alignment with what we want but it just
seems like
she's overly defensive
of my so when you say
the complexity that you have adhd i do
too i still have responsibilities and i
still got to treat people right i still
got to show up on time and get my stuff
done right
so when she gets defense does she get
defensive
she get upset with you about other
things besides just him
yeah it's almost like she's parenting
both
there you go that's what i was getting
at is she if both of y'all so is he
is he your younger brother right that's
what it feels like
okay so
i always want to go back with kids and
ask this question
or just make this statement ask this
question um
behavior is a language so what is my kid
trying to tell me here
number one they are telling me that i'm
not worth their time
number two they're telling me they don't
have to listen to me
and in this case both of those things
are true number because you don't have
to listen because mom's gonna back him
up
number three what's being modeled out
there right
like behaviors of language was being
modeled modeled is we can run over this
guy right mom
and so it sounds like you've got to back
out i know
your son's disrespect that think of that
as the flashing light letting you know
that the water is really choppy in your
boat
right your son's behavior here he's
unsafe
he is on a on a raft he's going up and
down up and down
because your marriage isn't fully
fully tethered in there how long have
you all been married man
uh two years two years how are things
they don't sound like they're good
well once we get past uh
once we get past her treatment like a
child in the house things are okay
mike that's everything that's like once
i get past
the explosive diarrhea i feel great
that's the problem that's why you don't
feel great right
yeah yeah that's true once once you get
past being
treated like a child acting like a child
belittled and
letting she lets her 11 year old son run
all over you things are awesome
right so what i'll tell you is man
things aren't awesome they're not
awesome existentially they're not
awesome relationally
um it sounds like you guys the kids are
second right now you've
as an adult with adhd you are a whirling
dervish of chaos is that fair
fair okay she has
raised a son on her own she now feels
like she's raising a second son
probably not because she's a jerk
probably because that's her defense
mechanisms that's all she knows
and she did this alone for seven years
then you came along she loves you she
wants you to be a part of her world
not to build a new our world and what
you all have to do
moving forward is building our world
together and it doesn't sound like
you've done that and now you brought
another kid into this which i think is
great good for you
now you got a two-year-old and they're a
whole host of chaos themselves right
they're a nuclear bomb of chaos in a
home
and so it's chaos chaos chaos and then
your wife's doubling down with the
things she knows
which is i'm going to be everybody's mom
i'm going to be everybody's caretaker
and so
i know you got to deal with the
disrespect of an 11 year old you really
do
and you can deal with the behavior part
of that right you can have firm
consequences you can have
um what i call preemptive preemptive
relational time we're going to spend 15
minutes together talking you can just
stare at me that's cool but i love you
you can get together as a family and
create um we did it on a canvas in our
house like a we are
board which is like here's here's the
the
we are the for the delony's right we are
people who have adventures we are people
who
say yes we're people who are treat each
other with dignity and then when
somebody violates that you point back to
it and say hey man you just opted out
of whatever's coming up next of
joining us in this event or whatever
because
you chose not to treat us with dignity
right and then mapping out for an 11
year old here's what disney looks like
here's what respect looks like you can
do all that but
none of that matters when mom and dad
aren't tethered
when kid is absorbing and watching
a dynamic that's not healthy and so i'm
going to suggest brother
you guys got to step back and it's a
good time anyway you got a two-year-old
your whole world just shifted
i suggest you all step back go sit
down the marriage counselor and maybe
for the first time in your marriage
be really really honest with one another
tell her that you feel like i'm your i'm
your kid i feel like you're parenting me
um and she may say you're acting like it
i have to
and once you can get past the feelings
and the emotions part and start minding
that stuff for what's true and what's
not true
then you can get to the activity part
you can get to the action part
who are we going to be together and then
you're going to model respect and
dignity to one another
and then you're going to be able to
tether your son to that
but that's the process the process with
a chaotic kid often starts with mom and
dad's relationship
first because he's just repeating what
he knows he's just
living out to what he sees so mike i'm
so grateful that you called me and i
know that's hard and i can hear it on
you
what i'll tell you is this you're worth
a hard conversation
you're worth going to marriage
counseling you are worth leaning into
this
and you're worth not being disrespected
by an 11 year old but it starts way
before that
okay and i want you to be a good dad for
both kids i want you to be a great
husband
and i want your wife to be a great wife
i want you to be great partners and i
want y'all to
just raise two extraordinary humans and
i think y'all can it's gonna start
with y'all getting back on the same page
and creating an our world
not a living in her world right all
right man so thanks for the call let's
go to
uh nevin in georgia nevin what's going
on
yes thank you for taking my call you got
it brother what's going on how can i
help
um so basically my question is
uh how to deal with grief
question um i lost
my son firstborn son here about
oh five five years ago
in 2015 and i'm so sorry and
it was a stillbirth and then we did have
a
healthy little girl a couple years later
and then
here two years ago um i lost
my next son to a complicated messed up
pregnancy and anyway my wife
is ready to move on and
try again but i guess
it's one of those things where i
i'm just ready to
hang it up on pregnancy yeah pretty
hesitant man
yeah well hey dude thanks for sharing
that i know that's hard to talk through
that
um tell me about your tell me about the
your two boys that passed away what were
their names
uh my first firstborn his name was
jackson yeah
and the one that just passed two years
ago
is hudson hudson beautiful man tell me
about your daughter uh
tavia she's my little firecracker about
four and a half right now
yeah into everything just as she should
be man
i have a firecracker four-year-old too
that's into everything man
um how did you and your wife grieve
these losses
well the first law
was an absolute shock yeah um
we everything was progressing normally
at 38 weeks
there got on the uneasy when we didn't
feel movement
went in for an ultrasound and no
heartbeat and
and so that one went down we we took
hard
right and then but then with uh with
hudson
we knew early on in the pregnancy that
there was
some major issues and so we were kind of
able to
over the course of the pregnancy kind of
how we
i mean we knew there was a very slim
chance of
survival for this child but we wanted to
give him every chance
yeah and then when when he was actually
born
um his abdomen was oak was open and
closed up
and he actually bled to death um
before they couldn't do anything and the
only response i got out of him
was when he was born i took his hand and
kind of squeezed my finger a little bit
and
his heart beat he never took a breath on
his own his heart beat for about 20
minutes
and then yeah that was you still feel
that squeeze every once in a while don't
you
yeah yeah so
after after the fact two months three
months six months later
that grief is still with you what does
it look like in your wife and what's it
look like with you
well i'm not sure exactly how i'm
supposed to answer that
did y'all just go but did you go back to
just the way things were was your wife
just automatically planning all right
well here's the next thing or
um did you start drinking a lot hang out
with your buddies did you find it hard
to wake up like what did what did
being sad what did owning this
this just suck what did that look like
in your home
well for my life
um i think
she probably took it the hardest at the
beginning
but um but yeah i think she probably did
hang out with her friends a little more
okay um for me
i've had a little bit of a tough time
oh i mean i have a couple close
friends but we've kind of drifted apart
over the last
year or so and i'm not i'm not really
close with anybody at the moment
okay but so here's the thing
few things can disrupt and fracture a
family
like mismatch grief or comparative
grief and sometimes
somebody just shuts it down for months
when they lose somebody when they lose a
pregnancy when they lose a parent when
they lose a spouse
they shut it down other people go into
meaning making mode and they just start
creating businesses and things
and getting fit and they deal with it
over the next four or five years
and some people fill in the blank some
people do something else some people do
something else
but if your wife went and met with
people and grieved and
wept and wrote letters and talked and
met with a counselor
and you just went to work and then you
just went to work and then you just went
to work and i'm just making this
up man okay well you're hitting it on
the head okay
at some point i would step back and say
she's gonna be way further down the road
of not getting over it you don't ever
get over this that's why i say you're
gonna feel that squeeze for the rest
your life
and i'm glad you are it's a powerful
important memory
but she's further down the road to
healing than you are
which makes her want to hit the gas
pedal again
a lot more likely and your foot is
jammed in on that on that break
because you've been in that car and it's
wrecked twice
and i'll be damned if i'm gonna do it
again right
and she's been in that car and it
wrecked twice and then she met with
people
and slowly took driver's education again
and got in a car with somebody else
driving for a season
and now she's ready to start driving
again right and so here's the thing
you my brother this has nothing to do
with whether you're gonna have another
kid or not that's down the road
what you have to do is decide i'm gonna
heal
not forget not toxic positive it's all
great we're
no dude but you're gonna have to decide
to let jackson
and hudson go be with the angels and
you're gonna have to
exhale and own the fact
and this is hard brother okay imagine me
and you sitting like
having a drink on the back of a tailgate
dude not just some dude on the radio
right so i'm not talking at you i'm
talking with you here you're gonna have
to decide
i'm ready to let those two boys go
they're always gonna be in my heart i'm
always gonna feel that squeeze but i
gotta let them go and i gotta heal
and more work and more busy and more
activity and more protection and bigger
walls and thicker bricks and all that
stuff isn't going to solve that
until you decide you're going to do that
and you and your wife
aren't shouldn't be talking about next
steps
until you've both talked through what
grieving feels like and looks like and
what you all dealt with when you haven't
dealt with
and then talk about where you are and
then talk about your son's names and
where they happen to be
and then be honest about your feelings
then be honest about the medical
challenges and then
then you're in a place to talk about
what comes next right
and right now i it doesn't sound like
you've healed man
and if you heal hey here's the thing
devin if you heal and land on a place
that i don't want any more kids
you're allowed to do that and that's
okay and then what i would tell your
wife
is if she is hell-bent on having a
a fourth child then it's not about
what's best for this kid because she's
gonna be bringing a kid in a situation
where dad's uncomfortable with this
it's gonna be about i need to have a kid
i need to have a kid my guess
is that either after a healing process
you would be ready to get back on the
wagon or after a joint healing process
process together
she's going to realize that more kids
aren't in the future but right now y'all
are living parallel
different lives and there's like i say
this is fracture this is how marriages
just
drift apart over time
yeah so yeah if it was just those two
because
i mean that's the only two of the deaths
we've been traumatized with since my
son's death
so i mean her brother died her sister
died from cancer my mom died from cancer
jeez it's been it's been a
absolute emotional roller coaster trying
to figure out how to navigate
this whole death loss but obviously
with my son it it's a lot
personal hey hey in my own family
all of those are personal right i know
i'm i understand
but yes what i mean is it's in my own
family unit that i live in with every
day
yeah that was your boy man yeah yeah
yeah
that was your boy and you're exactly
right man
and the last thing your brain and heart
and body wants you to do
is to get yet another relationship that
means something to you that you might
lose
yeah right and that's just your body
taking care of you man
it's just trying to keep the pain out
because it hurts and it hurts and it
hurts and at some point enough's enough
right
and that's the question i always want to
have for your wife too right that's
where a great
marriage counselor that you guys got to
go see about grief okay
is do we have another kid because we
think that's going to help
with the ache of this loss or are we now
healed and still and ready to add to our
family
and those are two different things
because what i'll tell you is
another child is not going to take away
the pain and the loss
it will give you joy and chaos and
mania and all the stuff that kids bring
right fun and bananas and no sleep all
that's good
but it will also not make the bad go
away
yeah and so when couples race out to
have another kid i always wanted to go
hey just breathe
just breathe because it's not going to
take that loss away
on the other side of it is when folks
are like nope never doing this again
never get back on the horse again never
never
never never here's what i'm going to
tell you nevin i've been in this boat
too
right and i was similar to you
i'm we we lost several pregnancies
one after the other after the other and
i said man i don't know
and my wife said i don't know and then
slowly we began to grieve
we had some hard conversations i didn't
know what was in her heart she didn't
know it was in mine
we finally and i do this for a living
dude and we finally sat down and we
finally
got about the business of healing and
then
as we were on the road to creating a new
tomorrow we had to create a new world a
new
our world because our current world was
ash
then we created something new and said
yeah now we're ready
and then that's how we got josephine and
it's awesome
it is awesome but again that's just our
journey every journey is different
brother you gotta heal y'all aren't in a
place to be asking
should we when are we gonna have another
kid or should we have another kid you
all are a place to
to to look at one another you just got
out of the ocean
you both saved one another and you
looked at each other and said are you
okay
and are you okay and one of you is going
to say i'm not okay the other
needs to go i'm not either
and then you got to be about getting
well and you got to be about coming back
together and you'll have to build a
whole
new marriage and that's not a bad thing
that's a good thing and it's hard and
it's exhausting and it's frustrating
that's where y'all are at and then when
you see the
sidewalks laid you see some some walls
going up that's when you can look at one
another with that look and say
you down for going again and now you can
have that conversation she's just not
there yet
okay i'm so grateful for your heart
thanks for sharing this man i know
that's a hard thing to talk about it's
hard to share
forget about healing get about healing
brother
and it's whatever it's worth man you're
worth getting well
you old man nevin you're working well
brother and i didn't believe it either
but i was worth it my son was worth it
my wife is worth it and you are too
all right i want to take a quick break
and answer one of the most common
questions i get
deloney i can't find a counselor in my
area or i can't afford one
listen help is here i've partnered with
better help for customized online
therapy
for you video therapy phone therapy
or you can even text with a licensed
therapist
in your area or somewhere across the
country to get the help
that you need when you need it go to
betterhelp.com
deloney for 10 off your first month
listen
online therapy is less expensive than
in-person therapy
i've taken away all of your excuses now
you have to recognize you're worth being
well
go see a counselor online with
betterhelp.com
today before we take this last call i
want to
just read this follow-up here this is
awesome um
so i got a follow-up from becca from
washington
and here's what she writes she says i
heard
your call on the last episode to put out
some positive energy in the world and
want to take this chance to brag on my
people
she called the show several months ago
about her husband going on deployment
and my advice was so helpful yes i told
my wife my advice is good sometimes
she here's what she writes he's
finishing up his deployment and he'll be
home soon
you asked me if i had a support system
and i said no i have no family near me
and we moved to this part of the country
about eight months ago but in the past
few months i've had more people rally
around my daughter and i than i could
have imagined
my kiddo is almost two and part tornado
awesome her daycare teacher is her
favorite person so when it's time for
her to move up to the next class i was
terrified
her teacher stepped up and offered to
practice walking into the new class
meeting with her new teacher every day
to get her used to it it was a seamless
transition
and my daughter handled it like a champ
my aunt cousins and siblings set up
weekly zoom call for us to do church
together
we talk and pray and that time has
become sacred to me
we never miss a week and my dad isn't
much of a communicator
but he sends my daughter books every few
weeks because he knows she loves to be
read to
good job grandad even stubborn old
grumpy granddads if you don't want to
talk cool
send books my husband man if i thought i
loved him before
i don't even know what to call it now
he's a beast that's a weird thing to say
after you said i loved him but it's cool
whatever
way to go becca um he's made rank and
completed several qualifications all
while being so supportive and present
for us
our relationship is growing our
communication has been phenomenal he
sends videos of himself
singing and talking to our daughter he's
a soldier on deployment
stay at home laying around working every
day and going back to your
suburban home dad and he can sing and
talk to his daughter you can too
and you get to do it in person i had no
idea support like this was a thing
thank you so much for your show forget
that becca thank you so much for writing
in and letting us know
if we have people in our corner guys we
can do hard
hard things we can do hard things with
people in our corner
good for you becca and good for you to
grandad to dad
to community to friends to teachers for
stepping up
and being that makeshift family that
makeship neighborhood for becca and her
little girl and um man thank you for
your stay-at-home service thank you for
your husband for his service
thanks to everybody for being involved
in that that is awesome that is awesome
all right let's take one more call let's
go to kayla in salt lake city
hey kayla what's going on hello thank
you for taking my call
thanks for calling how can i help so i
have a question
of get some advice on
healing for my family after
i recently brought up charges against my
cousin
for repeatedly sexually abusing me 32
years ago
okay so what what brought you to this
decision
well hold on let me stop for let me stop
for a second
i should have said this before that
you're brave
you're a a lion and i'm proud to know
you
kayla i appreciate it i had to do it it
was something i
i had to do to protect other girls
good for you man that's hard hard hard
stuff and that choice is yours
and i'm proud of you for making the
choice that was right for you all right
so
now tell me about what it's been like
okay so um he repeatedly sexually abused
me when i was five years old
in 1988 and i never told any anybody
until i was 12 years old i told my mom
and dad
but my entire family they they all knew
about it but they just swept it under
the rug
pretending nothing ever happened nothing
well
fast forward about 20 years
and he or 15 20 years he got charged
10 years ago for sexually abusing his
stepdaughter
and he only did six months in jail and
was released
well three years ago he got charged for
doing it to his biological daughter
but the charges got dismissed because
she was afraid to testify
on the stand against him well when i
read the article
two years ago about that and i found out
that he'd been
charged for doing it to his biological
daughter too
i just like snapped and i had to come
forward
and tell my story to an investigator
because somebody needed to stand up
against him and
um and that's what i did and he picked
up
multiple charges of first degree
felonies and he's been sitting in jail
for a year and a half
awaiting trial but this has caused
a big can of worms to open in my family
especially with his mother
who's my aunt and his sisters who are my
cousins
they ref they hate my guts now they
refuse to talk to me hey you know what
caleb
ridiculous i don't i they're not worth
the air you breathe
they're not worth the air you breathe
your parents
left you as a child high and dry
there's predators and pieces of crap
everywhere that's life
it sucks but that's life and we do what
we can to keep them off the streets
that's why we have parents that's why we
have cousins
that's why we have aunts and uncles
that's why we have friends and community
members and church members and people
who've got our backs
and yours let you down and so
how dare they circle back and try to
roll this over on you
no no
so then i just um i just uh
just have it they're out of my life for
good not by your hand
just leave it that way what like they
they walked away from you right they
chose a child molester
over somebody who was injured somebody
who was hurt
for years yes and they did it for years
and then they allowed it caused other
girls to get hurt yes
they cho you don't want to associate
with them anyway
yeah well i i don't i just i wish i
could
conk him over the head so that he had
some common sense listen
you can't they're not going to they're
never going to anybody's going to stand
up for a repeat
child molester is not something that you
can solve
right you dust your dirt off your
sandals and you walk out
and i know that's heartbreaking and
that's lonely not because of
them per se but because now you're
lonely
now there's consequences to your
boundaries and that's
hard and i get that but i'm just
telling you as a as a dad of a daughter
thank you for being bold and brave and
strong
even though it's 20 years thank you
thank you for
keeping that piece of garbage
once my daughter turned five that's when
this all like
opened up inside me that i couldn't stop
anymore like i had to do something
that's exactly right your body's alarms
go off because it sees another
it's easy you walking right in front of
it right every morning at breakfast time
it sees it
right yeah yeah so
so do you have any advice for me um how
what would be the best like what should
i do
to um this is a going a giant step
towards healing
of him finally being in jail and being
off the streets and
you know hopefully he gets convicted and
does a long long time yeah but um
what um advice do you have for me to
fully heal from this so i i'm going to
give you a statement a comment about
the the jail part that um i testified
against somebody in jail once
um that committed a crime and they got a
lot of
um it was it was a pretty ugly crime and
they got a lot of jail time
and i called a friend of mine she's a
mentor of mine she's a
psychologist who works with abused kids
and when the verdict was read the next
day i felt sick
and i thought i would feel awesome like
yeah that's what's
up and i felt gross i felt terrible
like just gross and i called her and
said i don't understand these feelings
and she said john nobody wins
everybody's life is destroyed with
with childhood sexual abuse everyone
yeah
right and so you will there will be a
level of safety to where hey this person
can't get to me anymore and that's real
and good
and there might be that cheery like yeah
moment
if there's a verdict that that comes
down
but i don't want you to think you're
going to feel good
well i haven't felt great through the
whole problem
the whole thing is awful right and so
here's the first question and this is an
important question and i
i'm asking this because i love you not
not as a way of poking okay
and there's times um that this question
gets asked and people can weaponize the
way they
ask this and i'm not doing that okay i'm
i'm with you on this conversation okay
okay are you ready to be done with this
and here's here before you answer here's
what i mean
when we hang on when we
loop the story when we hang on to it
tight
it feels like protection it feels like
hyper vigilance it feels like
nobody's gonna ever get me again i i'll
be damned if i'm gonna let that happen
no one's coming for me no one's gonna if
they do they're gonna there's gonna be
there's gonna be hell to pay
right it feels like this stressed alert
vigilant
like i am i am protecting myself i'm
protecting my daughter
and that keeps you alive now and it
kills you tomorrow
that level of stress circulation that
level of vigilance always on always on
always on
wears out your your adrenaline and your
cortisol
it just slowly grinds your body down and
so when i ask you
are you ready to be done that means
not i'm ready to just um go have an
abusive situation again no are you ready
to stop
carrying this guy in your backpack this
brick
yes i'm ready to stop carrying it
and the five-year-old inside of me had
to come forward and
get some justice to finish it off and
now i want her to be able to go
be a five-year-old right
right and i want you to be able to raise
your was she six seven eight nine now
your daughter and let her have the fun
joyful like learn how to be a strong
powerful woman like her mom i want her
to be able to
like have that world right and so here's
a couple of things you can do to help
or you're to heal right number one real
important is to become aware of your
body's response
the physical part of it and learn to
honor it and let it complete the cycles
right and that's from emily nagatsky's
new work i love it
um but it's this idea of
when you feel your heart start racing
when you feel those those thoughts start
looping on you when your hands get
clean whatever it is with that you feel
right when you're in the presence of
somebody
a guy that makes you feel uncomfortable
when you find yourself here or there
you know that kicks in right
when you yeah notice that and begin to
honor that
oh here it goes man my body's trying to
protect me and you can slowly distance
yourself from it
not as a thing that you are but it's
just a thing that's happening in your
body
and then you can begin to ask hey what's
it trying to protect me from
oh that guy's safe he's all right i know
that guy
he's goofy and he's silly and his jeans
are way too tight he's got a mustache
but i like that guy right so
it's beginning it's becoming aware of
how your body's responding
right and then when it does take off on
you do you have
anxiety attacks or panic attacks or do
you have moments of rage like what what
what's still
how does it emerge in your body this
many years later
um i'm not really anxiety or rage like i
think i'm
past all that because it's you know so
many years
so but i've just been wanting it to be
like
i feel like um
it's hard to explain um
i just feel like the the the little girl
that was inside of me that
that happened to the five-year-old she
needs to be heard
and and she needs somebody to listen
damn so here's what i want you to do
will you do me this favor
i want you to write that five-year-old
girl a letter
and from i want you to write her three
letters okay
are you ready yeah letter number one
is gonna be the letter from your parents
what they should have said
okay okay and i want you to write a
letter from you to her
letting her know that what happens not
okay
and that you're so sorry that nobody
protected her when they should have
but now you're going to
okay and then the third letter is i want
you to write her a letter letting her
know
who you're going to become how you're
going to make meaning of this this many
years later what kind of mom you're
going to be
what kind of professional you're going
to be what kind of community and
neighbor you're going to be
and then get into that letter sounds
like a good idea i want you to let that
girl go i want you to let her
go go play
okay i really appreciate you talking to
me
no i appreciate you calling and here
here's here's um
are you married now yeah i just recently
got married okay and i'm pregnant with
uh my fourth baby
hey there you go because fourth
man you're you're a bad man pajama all
right
here's what i want you to do and this is
going to be a bold step for you okay
this new guy he's all right oh he's
wonderful
okay so here is the evil
beyond the evil there's 18 layers of
evil with childhood abuse
18 layers of just demo that's why it
rages through family genera like
linny just for years it's because the
only thing that keeps a person well
and whole insane and alive
is vulnerable connection to other people
in childhood sexual abuse particularly
tells a child that safe relationships
don't exist
and in fact relationship is the core
of the worst pain you can experience
and so what you're gonna have to do at
your as as a
about to be mama of four is you're gonna
have to
learn how to be in relationship
how to roll over and expose your belly
again be vulnerable again
and risk getting hurt again because
that's the only way you're going to be
fully vested with this new knucklehead
you just married
and what you're going to have and here's
the thing that makes sense it's scary
and it's hard and here's the thing i
want you to hear me say
you got to practice it it's something
you learn how to do
we think we just know how to do
relationships we don't we all suck at it
we're terrible and so if you go into it
saying hey honey we're going to take
dancing lessons
or we're going to learn how to build a
cabinet we're going to go to this little
class with the ymca
how to build a cabinet that's what
you're doing but i want you to tell them
i want to be so plugged in with you
and that starts with me learning how to
heal
with me saying i'm never carrying this
dude's crap for another
second i'm gonna do the work i'm gonna
write the letters and let this
five-year-old girl go be
and then bubba you don't even know
what's coming for you right
i'm gonna love you in a way that you
ain't ever been loved and i'm expecting
you to love me back that way and that's
just something we got to practice and
learn together
right well that sounds great and we both
deserve it
hey you do kayla you super dude
what's his name trent
kaitlyn trent that just sounds romantic
kayla and trent
both of you deserve it and
um my heart tells me you just got to
learn it
and that's okay and that's so good
you're it's give me 70
and be like you know what i'ma learn how
to do vulnerable connection because i'm
gonna have the last 20 years of my life
be intertwined with other people good
for you kayla
good for you you are a brave powerful
lion
cheetah awesome stud woman i'm so proud
of you
and um i can't wait to hear how this
goes let me know how
how it goes after you write those
letters let me know what kind of
relationship counseling you get into you
and trent
big t and let us know when that fourth
baby's born and we'll celebrate here on
the show thank you so much for your call
kayla and thanks for being brave all
right so as we wrap up today's show
man this is off one of my favorite
records of all time
i just remember the only way i could
think of this when this came on mtv back
in 1992 for those of you who don't know
mtv used to be a channel it was on the
televisions that had music videos
um now they don't have that but it used
to and it was rad
and i had to sneak it when my parents
were gone
social distortion came on with their new
record somewhere between heaven and hell
and they had this song that just they
just looked cool man
i don't know that we said i haven't
watched the video in years it might be
awful and terrible
please don't send me mean cards and
letters i just remember as like an 11
year old being like these guys
these guys they're slicked back here the
song is called bad luck
and it goes something like this not
something like this it goes exactly like
this here it goes
some people like to gamble but you you
always lose and some people like to rock
and roll and you're always singing the
blues
you got a nasty disposition and no one
really knows the reason why
you got a bad bad reputation gonna hang
down your head and cry this kind of
sounds like kelly
you got bad bad luck you just got bad
luck
13 is my lucky number to you it means
stay inside black cat done crossed my
path no reason to run and hide
you're looking through a cracked mirror
no one really knows the reason why
your enemies are getting nearer gonna
hang your head and cry
you got bad luck
you're always scratching at the eight
ball and no one knows why
you get on the top and then you fall
you're gonna hang your head down and cry
brother you just got bad luck kelly
that's not you you're beautiful and kind
and this has been the dr john daloni
[Music]
show